the final warm-up for the long-awaited
start of the delayed baseball season
local Inchon favorites SK wyverns
take on visitors Hanwha Eagles but
conspicuously absent from the stands
their fans instead many of the seats
occupied by printed versions of
spectators while real fans can only
watch on TV or online through a club
stream that combines the action in the
park with the cheering in homes
[Music]
penny-ante look girl gone we are hoping
to deliver some of the atmosphere of the
stadium to the fans at home so they feel
as though they are here at the game
they're also joined by potentially
millions of baseball fans around the
world as the 3rd ranked baseball playing
nation after the u.s. and Japan South
Korea's live games are in big demand in
a world starved of live sports action we
welcome the increased attention on
Korean baseball it's great to promote it
and it's all thanks to our citizens for
getting us to this stage South Korea's
success so far in defeating the
coronavirus is also allowing the
football K League to start its season
later this week but again without fans
in another sport for which large
cheering crowds seem indispensable so
crowds are important because they are
part of what we expect when we got to
see a game or when we watch a game the
noise the tension the drama the anxiety
the happiness the emotion this is this
is not driven by empty stadiums this is
driven by full stadiums
South Korea's baseball teams hope to
start adding the essential fan
ingredient soon even when the fans are
finally allowed back in it'll still be a
long time before we see packed stands
again their numbers will increase only
gradually with empty seats between them
and for now they're silent standings
we'll have to do and when they do return
they'll find previously unheard-of
precautions for the players
such as no hugging and no spitting the
way baseball is played and the way it's
watched is turning into a very different
game
Robert bride al Jazeera in Xi'an South
Korea